hi guys I'm Eric Voss and we here with
new rock stars are looking back at what
we consider to be the best in television
from 2017 and by television we mean
episodic stories that we tend to watch
on TV even if they come from places like
Netflix or Hulu hey TV is dying what a
time to be alive now to be clear these
are our top 10 TV shows of 2017 and yes
we did lead out a lot of great TV
amazing series like the Americans
American Gods American big little wise
USA's mr. robot this video is patriotic
propaganda aren't on this list but
there's still excellent series that you
should definitely go check out but these
are the 10 that we really like this year
and feel like saying things about
starting with number 10 Marvel's The
Punisher on Netflix now I have a soft
spot in my heart for this in a lot of
ways Jon Bernthal can really do no wrong
in my eyes and for me these episodes did
so much to restore the Marvel Netflix
universe to what I loved about the first
season of daredevil that alone kids at a
spot on our new rockstars top ten and
yes adapt eight superheroes faithfully
is weirdly important to us what more
reasons why we love The Punisher go
check out Sam's breakdown and everything
you missed from that season moving on to
number 9 better call Saul season 3 on
AMC now followers of this channel maybe
weren't aware of this but last spring I
was waging a secret war behind the
scenes to do weekly breakdowns a better
call Saul not everyone is as obsessed
with it as I am so obviously I lost that
war but I'm kind of winning a battle
within that war right now Breaking Bad
it was my favorite show of all time and
better call Saul is the best possible
sequel to it season 3 tied the universes
together bringing in one of the best TV
villains of all time Gustavo Fring
squaring them off with the lifelong
enemy and greatest angry face ever
Hector Salamanca trust me if you at all
enjoy Breaking Bad and you missed the
dark commie and occasional freaky
violence better call Saul season 3 is
worth a watch next up number 8 The
Handmaid's Tale on Hulu now guessing
you've heard of this show before maybe
you've just seen some in the real world
protests with women in red robes from
the show yes it's a super politically
relevant show with some terrifying
parallels to current events I am a
sucker for dystopian future fiction
especially when it stays fiction and
this app tation of Margaret Atwood's
novel about a religious cult that takes
over the government and forces women to
be a slave class for forced breeding is
just so perfectly executed by Elizabeth
moss and the whole team the acting set
designed wardrobe camerawork everything
pulls on some amazing tricks with a
character's limited point of view that
I've never seen a TV show before moving
on to number 7
another darling and my personal book
American vandal on Netflix
true crime documentaries and podcasts
have been all over the place in recent
years and American vandal parodies that
trend so well now if you aren't familiar
it's basically serial or making a
murderer set in a high school with the
mystery being who drew a bunch of dicks
on the teachers cars and of course it
explores this crime with the level of
detail investigative journalism that the
researchers on making a murderer did
which is hilarious but somehow it tricks
you into actually caring about this
mystery and the characters involved
another amazing comedy that
unfortunately can't really devote
resources to cover here is number six on
our list
Nathan for you season four on Comedy
Central now I know on the surface if you
don't watch it the show seems kind of
flat and simple but beneath and Nathan
fielders friendly facade as a business
advise host is a dark uncomfortably
intimate in hilarious cry for help past
guests on his show become running jokes
forming a rich universe of broken toys
the season 4 finale follows the most
fascinating of these weirdos a lonely
Bill Gates impersonator searching the
country for an old flame which totally
overtakes the show's normal format just
trust me just watch a new episodes of
the show you won't be disappointed
moving on to some shows our subscribers
might be more familiar with number 5
Rick and Morty's season 3 on Adult Swim
covering Rick and Morty on this channel
was one of my true delights this year
from the surprise premiere released on
April Fool's Day through pickle rick and
the epic return of evil morty it remains
the best comedy on TV the best sci-fi on
TV and the one show where i genuinely
never have any idea where it's going why
isn't it higher on this list you crazed
Herman head might be screaming at your
screen right now
I don't know while still amazing looking
back a few of the episodes just gonna
slip through the cracks of my memories
somewhere between where I was at 9/11
and my favorite sports bloopers
god I just sound like reddit it's a
great show just go watch my crazy
breakdowns for proof of how much I love
it another show we just couldn't get
around to covering but man you know how
a few years ago everyone was talking
about how true detective was so great
and they were calling it 7 but a TV
series at least that's what I call true
detective but mine honor is truly a
serialized version of 7 it's even got
the same director David Fincher behind
it Fincher is in my opinion the finest
director in the business and he's known
for doing an obsessive number of takes
and that obsession and meticulous
attention to detail weaves its way into
the fabric of the show in the characters
with Jonathan Groff
an FBI agent in the 70s with a fetish
level fascination with serial killers
when the term serial killer was still
being invented the show even kinda
messes with your head - with super
creepy cult opens showing a serial
killer in the making - slow burn but man
is it entertaining
we've been on at number three how could
we leave this off the list Game of
Thrones Season seven on HBO
us watching Game of Thrones is what I
imagine people who care about sports do
when they watch games like I assume the
Patriots have nerd equivalents breaking
down the Shakespeare references right no
that's because we're nuts and season 7
gay fans pretty much everything on our
wish list
Arya killing all the phrasing reuniting
with new mariya check his ami dragon
blowing down the wall check John
revealed as a Targaryen and banging his
aunt Daenerys check yeah I I wanted to
see that I am I got I got issues season
7 wasn't entirely perfect there was the
whole matter of John's and possible
mission north and the relatively
pointless Sansa Arya feud and a weird
amount of poop jokes with Sam at the
Citadel but despite these hiccups Game
of Thrones remains the truly epic
experience that's impossible not to get
wrapped up in 2019 cannot come soon
enough
moving on to number two stranger things
- on Netflix the second season of
stranger things ended up being every bit
the delight of the first season was and
yes the perfectly written and cast kids
were largely to thank but let's be clear
here Bob and Steve Harrington were the
true heroes these two were the step dad
and stepmom that any kid in a tease
dealing with interdimensional D&D
monsters could ask for and ever that
Steve and Dustin would make such a great
power couple but oh man give these two a
spinoff and you feel like crying the
show snuck in the sweetest Easter egg
and he can find out what it was by
watching a breakdown and that brings us
to number one on our list what I
consider to be the best series of 2017
Legion on FX remember what I said about
adapting superheroes well well Legion is
the most creative visually daring and
thoughtful adaptation of a Marvel
character that I have ever seen on
screen on TV or on film showrunner Noah
Holly took a lesser-known figure from
the x-men comics and created a universe
that's all removed from any of the
cinematic ones that we've seen visually
it has more in common with the shining
or Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind
or a kaleidoscope the season unfolds as
a super vibrant colorful mine
that's fascinating to try to decode that
somehow keeps you engaged and explains
everything you need to know precisely at
the right moments honestly everything
about this show is just perfect the
villain is terrifying and Aubrey Plaza
plays the role of her career just stop
what you're doing right now and go watch
Legion okay that was my list but
obviously there is way more great TV out
there that I did include here which I'm
sure you'll tell me about in the
comments but I do want to hear from you
what do you think was the best show of
2017 and what show are you most looking
forward to in 2018 like and share this
video and subscribe to new rockstars for
deep dives into a lot of these shows and
coverage of all the stuff that you love
tweet me a DA vas or follow new
rockstars on Twitter at new rock stars
thanks for watching guys bye